alors là je voudrais juste avoir une
pensée pour ses parents parce que ses
parents ce moment ils ont des vraiment
on a annoncé leur adresse ils habitent
trop loin de paris ils ont des menaces
quotidiennes il a mis en scène la maman
qui pleure donc ça aujourd'hui c'est
quoi alors non non mais je veux dire la
recommencer comme ça c'est encore ça il
dit nous a dit sur le plateau ça fait
deux ans qui fait des choses qui sont
quand même très polémique non mais c'est
vrai qu'on revienne sur cet extrait de
ces il attise encore là l'air pour
essayer que ça choque et je parle de
vous ah bah moi moi oui il va évidemment
mais c'est plus ou pas là ah non mais là
je fais là je peux pas j'ai déjà l'autre
jour c'était sûr mais ça scandaleux mais
la lie et voilà c'est la surenchère
c'est nous a dit on nous a dit de
l'autre jour moi je m'excuserai pas il
le fait comme ça c'est une surenchère ce
je ne peux pas supporter ça c'est je
pense moi en priorité là à ses parents
parce que c'est un petit con voilà
excusez moi je trouve même qu'on lui
donne beaucoup trop d'importance et une
tribune beaucoup plus important
c'est dit
moi pour moi c'est un enfant perdu sa
roue ainsi ses ambiances et les réseaux
sociaux c'est un enfant perdu des
réseaux sociaux donc après bon là il a
mis un col roulé il a mis un pull je
veux dire il n'a pas tout fait et il a
il sait bien habillé pour faire sa vidéo
moi je lui en veux pas parce que pour
moi c'est un petit coup et je me dis
qu'il faut pas non plus s'acharner sur
lui il faut pas lui faire là de sa vie
un enfer je veux bien qu'il ya plein de
gens qui soit blessé je suis la cible en
plus donc je je je me sens aussi
concernés par ce qu'il a fait mais là
les gars il a mis un col roulé il a fait
a vite fait il à faire lever deux jambes
ce qui moi me fait de millas silence et
tout le monde est apparu calme et rick
elisa vous mêlez selon les dires le trou
dès a vu les messages vendredi n'a vu la
défaite et il a reçu des messages et moi
je vous ai regardé vendredi et je vous
entends des touches pas bon ça c'est un
enfant ça un enfant il a 18 ans et
regardent et il a dit on à en parler
c'est un enfant 18 ans à 18 ans j'étais
au taf j'étais pas un enfant il ya des
gens à 18 ans ils ont déjà des
responsabilités
je connais avec à 18 ans je veux dire il
a quitté sa province
18 ans tu peux tu peux comprendre le
respect le respect des institutions des
églises des mosquées des synagogues et
tu peux comprendre que tu vas blessés
des religieux à 18 ans
[Musique]
vous avez
l'air bien son frère pas celui de black
pour une fois mais il pense qu'il
devrait être suivi
je pense que humainement c'est important
aussi le climat il devrait être suivi
parce que ce sont des traumatismes qui
me décrit ce sont des appels au secours
en effet quand je ne sais pas si il voit
un psychologue ou psychiatre mais il
faudrait qu'il en parle à un
professionnel parce qu'on voit comme une
montée comme ça en crescendo et ça on un
jour on pourrait vraiment exagéré match
et là des gens il est champion
alors s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il permettait cela derrière cela
déroule derrière vous je voudrais
m'excuser voulez vous au point
de vraiment je ne comprends pas vraiment
c'est quelqu'un qui est fragile
je m'embrouille avec toi je vais bien
rasé ont rejoint je vais pisser sur ta
voiture en main armée
après je et bien c'est presque une
clause il use kids moi j'emmène doses
mais non on n'est pas une dose sans la
blesser des gens gilles quand même